KYLE KEANE: So now you're going
to either just cluster shyly
with the people
that are near you,
or stand up, and look across
the room, and be like,
is anybody else trying to make
eye-contact with other people?
And then like, ah, there you go.
And then walk over
and be like, hi,
do you want to work together--
[LAUGHTER]
And then sit down and work it.
So be friendly with
sharing your chairs.
[SIDE CONVERSATION]
And then one of you pulls up
the Roll-a-ball video tutorial.
MARK: This page?
KYLE KEANE: Yeah.
And then one or
multiple of of you
have your computer
out with Unity
open, and start
playing the tutorial,
and pause it, and
be extroverted.
Be like, hey, can we
pause it real quick
so I can look up that function?
Or I would like to try do
this other crazy thing.
Is it OK if I do that?
Ask for things that you want.
If you have a weird impulse
to try to do something,
ask If you're asking
too many questions
and your teammate is
annoyed, then they
can get up and go
to another team.
Because I'm telling
you, you should
be asking questions in here.
And you should be interacting.
So-- and if you happen
to be really quiet,
and you find a
really quiet group
that just watches the video
straight through and never
talks, fine.
I'm not going to
force anybody to talk.
But feel free to talk.
Talking is good.
So this is very self-organized.
And you are free
to do as you wish.
I'm going to go check
on the Arduino class
and make sure that
chaos hasn't broken out.
And then I will be back
in about 20 minutes.
And I'll probably see you all
clustered around the room.
Feel free to go grab
chairs if you need them.
MARK: Rearrange desks?
KYLE KEANE: Yeah,
rearrange desks us.
If you want to take
somebody's desk,
then ask them if you
can use their desk
so you can be close to the group
that you made eye-contact with.
You guys are good.
MARK: Also, quick
recommendation.
At some point, you're going
to encounter the video up top.
And then a script
is down below so you
can more clearly read it.
I would highly recommend
not just copying this
into the Unity Editor.
It will work.
But by typing it out, you
get a much better idea
of what you're doing, especially
if you're following it
in real time, rather than
just Control-C, Control-V.
KYLE KEANE: So if you
feel rushed in your group,
then be like, hey,
Kyle said you should--
that we take our time--
[LAUGHTER]
And speak up a little bit.
And take your time
typing it out.
If you're like, why
are there freaking
periods between every word?
Ask your group.
And if nobody understands,
then ask another group.
Because that's a
super valid question.
There's a lot of meaning in why
there's periods between words
and why there's round brackets
rather than square brackets.
And if you have weird
questions like that,
you're asking the
right question.
Ask your group.
If they don't
know, then it's not
your fault for asking a question
that was hard to answer.
It's everyone else's
responsibility
to find the information
to answer that question.
So you can try Mark or I. I
don't have all the answers.
Or you can try another group.
Inter-group dialogue is
the coolest thing ever.
So if you guys get there
today, I'll be very impressed.
But usually it takes a few
days before people really
get extra prudent.
MARK: Yeah-- hopefully, at
some point, when you guys get
to this line of code, it's
kind of a weird concept,
and you should ask.
KYLE KEANE: Yes.
So there are points where
you should be confused.
All right, so
free-wheeling chaos.
Let chaos reign for a minute.
Find people and
make eye contact.
Smile, that helps.
It signals to other humans
that you're friendly.